this is a landfill in the sagramonte Oh
National Park home to the world's
tallest peak Mount Everest members of
the sagramonte Pollution Control
Committee or SPCC collect and sort trash
all the way up to Everest base camp
situated in the Himalaya Everest is more
than 29,000 feet above sea level at its
peak it has been an elite climbing
destination for decades and hundreds of
climbers from all over the world visit
each year to attempt to summit the peak
tourism and trekking in the valleys
below Everest has grown significantly in
the last 30 years now reaching over
35,000 visitors per year the increased
tourism has led to an increase in trash
and plastics and landfills now dot the
National Park
Angora Sherpa is the chairman of the
SPCC and has lived and worked in cigar
Motta for most of his life possess was
already named Jay Allison Sienna did
here Rodney temprano her channel
suppressed Hannah recipe with you
carpool an illness not Betty with a
crusade number the tree shake thump or
they were telling her the era the
mountain Bahama our core number born a
bit icky today her poor Milo company
item sapped a body
I mean Teddy Haruna beneath the worst
Athena
you value the most is you never know
Christina turn on the arena so better
for a forty to forty there was a novel
idea reservoir to the Quranic
savasana would be tomatillo that the
Chinese have an SPCC members carry the
trash to designated sites word is
eventually burned or buried they've
enjoyed the trails appear clean but the
trash remains in landfills and waste
pits around the corner from tourist
hotspots at the moment they have few
alternatives many SPCC employees are
contracted by the Nepalese government to
work as mountain guides and Icefall
doctors some of the most dangerous tasks
on Everest they install aluminum ladders
over chasms and cracks in the ice along
the Everest climbing route crucial to
set climbers up for success to summit
the peak the SPCC hopes to grow the
waste management system but for now they
want to encourage tourists and trekkers
to gather and remove trash from the park
over your spring my damn Leo does a gear
this was when I was home I never see you
have no consideration here for
garbage management MA Chris Leben
involve Ronnie for this home whenever
see partake reality Achilles train Forte
come remover to take our mothers nope
readiness Minami gravidarum ROM ribbit
ARMA possesses our will be dissing porn
early madam up but a sporty sadly
material yemeni purchases are kilo for
Jacob Ruppert sermons Emily while Nepal
is moving to curb the number of climbers
other reforms will be needed to keep the
world's most coveted mountainous peak in
sagramonte a national park clear of
trash about maybe tomorrow a pediment
and the units are dispersed emerging
over you put on the Turkish rebuilt open
England a correlative Cassidy recycle
gurney for like a sea of psychology me
poor elizacass tree fruit botany
but we minimize Tom Werner when you grow
impossible to the Challenger
rahamallah a litany poor mobility about
your mutter paneer me multi Sofia granny
again take on the song